look just work work really really hard
and don't give up I know that's really
simple but it will it it works my name
is Daniel Houghton I'm the CEO of Lonely
Planet and I'm 28 years old we've been
around for a little while we were
founded in 1973 initially just
guidebooks - these days virtually every
place in the world and over the last
forty seven years that's evolved to be a
real multimedia business from our
presence on the web to magazines to
mobile apps and sort of everything in
between we actually go everywhere we
write about which in an age of machine
learning and a lot of automation it's
nice to have content that you can trust
because someone actually went there
[Music]
I have loved travel for a really long
time I tried to set up my career to be a
photographer and photo journalist and
did that for a couple years
opportunities presented themselves and
been really fortunate I've just tried to
work really hard and pursue those have
always just been in love with the
business and it's just really neat to
have anything to do with it I pumped gas
at a marina at a lake in Alabama growing
up my dad pulled up to the boat dock one
day and said what are you doing just
standing around better pick up a broom
and start sweeping something you can't
that with my job is to pump gas and no
one's here it doesn't matter you know
always always sort of have a boom in
your hand if that makes sense and be
working
[Music]
there you know there's been many things
that I've tried in the business to get
done and you fail several times in a row
in upon hindsight it's no it's never fun
to be unsuccessful at something but a
lot of times that that ends up leading
you down a much better path
[Music]